foreign
between some of the biggest Titans that
ever roamed the Earth
today we're going back in time to see
two terrifying predators
from the jungle Marsh to the deep ocean
you can expect a Megalodon titanoboa
fight to be an epic brawl that will go
down in history
how could this Mega Snake overpower the
mega shark
what superpower would give the shark an
advantage
and which animal would Tower over the
other
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a Megalodon fought a Titanoboa
okay before the Carnage begins let's
break down the stats on these Fighters
the Megalodon is one of the largest
predators that ever lived
these sharks hunted in the oceans 20
million years ago but they went extinct
3.6 million years ago
growing to a length of 18 meters these
beasts measured three times longer than
the largest great white shark ever
recorded
and check out this massive jaw spanning
three meters wide with
276 teeth inside
that jaw is strong enough to crush a car
but will this killer meet its match
against the Fearsome Titanoboa
in this corner lies a prehistoric snake
that could haunt your dreams the
Titanoboa
this serpent lived during the paleocene
epoch which ended 56 million years ago
After The Dinosaurs went extinct
titanoboa became the top predator
slithering around on land
measuring an average of 13 meters and
weighing about one and a quarter tons
this snake could roam unchallenged it
dominated its Terrain
but a new Challenger has entered
while this snake was known to devour
giant turtles fish and reptiles the
Megalodon might just take a bite out of
the Titanoboa
so let's get down to the main event the
only reason you clicked play
this prehistoric Grudge Match has been
millions of years in the making
but where could these Giants duke it out
they both thrived in warmer climates but
the Megalodon lives in the ocean and
titanoboa slides through the jungles
you'd have to lure the shark into
mangroves or an estuary where the fresh
water meets the sea
the Megalodons amazing sense of smell
might detect the giant snake first
or it could use its incredible
superpower some sharks have Electro
receptors that detect electrical Fields
the energy that their prey generates
this ability could allow the Meg to
strike first
but this Serpentine Predator has a few
tricks of its own
titanoboa stock did spray by hiding in
water or between trees and waiting for
the perfect moment to strike which might
take days
if the Megalodon swims right under the
snake the Titanoboa could attack before
the shark knows what hit it
if the snake dives into the water it
could sink its curved teeth into the
shark and as the Megalodon thrashes
around those meat hooks would dig deeper
and deeper into the shark's flesh
the serpent would coil itself tightly
around its prey and squeeze hard trying
to choke the life out of the Megalodon
with over
276 kilopascals of pressure the
Titanoboa could really put the squeeze
on the Megalodon
but sharks don't have lungs they have
gills that absorb oxygen from the water
and while that massive snake's jaw opens
1.8 meters wide it's not enough to
swallow this aquatic Beast hole
titanoboa needs to crush the Megalodon
and collapse its organs or block its
Gill openings
if the snake can drag the shark into
shallow water this fight is over but in
deeper waters the Megalodon could use a
high-speed assault and attack from
underneath
the Furious shark would use its jaws of
death to maim and disable the snake
violently shaking the titanoboa's body
in moments those razor-sharp teeth would
split the snake in two
the battle between these two Titans
would depend on which Contender Finds
Its opponent first
it would be a test of patience and
Savage strength between Giants who are
anything but sluggish or slow
but since these monsters didn't live at
the same time well we'll never know for
sure how this match would have gone down
but what if you witnessed a fight
between a Megalodon and its ancient
rival the Leviathan whale
well keep watching because that's a
story for another
what if
[Music]